[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace Centroamérica desde
San Salvador hablaremos de la recta
final del mandato el presidente nayib
bukele quien luego de cuatro años en el
gobierno mantiene una alta aceptación
entre la población y la región a lograr
el desplome del número de homicidios
atribuidos a las pandillas pero con
múltiples críticas de ongs y organismos
internacionales por las violaciones a
los Derechos Humanos
a raíz de las acciones de esos grupos
criminales El Salvador era considerado
como una de las naciones más violentas
del mundo ahora la realidad se muestra
diferente para un país acostumbrado a la
muerte
en la campanera un suburbio de las
afueras de la capital Joel Ayala afirma
que su pequeño negocio al fin tiene un
respiro luego de estar sometido por
parte de las pandillas al pago de
extorsiones tras un cálculo rápido
aseguró que en 10 años entregó 85 mil
dólares a estos grupos desde que bukele
ordenó imponer el régimen de excepción
hace 14 meses el férreo control de las
pandillas en esta zona y en el resto del
país parece inexistente
en el pasado no tenía el control el
estado acá
en la Colonia y en el país entero por
completo
Hoy sí se siente que ya el estado tiene
el control porque ya no mandan ya no
mandan las pandillas en el país sino que
manda ya el estado
tratándose de las medidas de seguridad
que ha tomado el gobierno ha
implementado el gobierno Esto está bien
para un progreso el régimen de excepción
no solo significó una mayor
militarización en las calles sino
también luz verde para realizar arrestos
sin orden judicial una 69.000 personas
han sido encarceladas por pertenecer
presuntamente a las pandillas según el
gobierno en la actualidad unas 5000 han
sido liberadas por no encontrárceles
vínculos con estas estructuras
criminales
con el estado de excepción vigente en el
2022 el país tuvo una tasa de homicidios
por cada cien mil habitantes de siete
coma ocho cifras oficiales
contraste cuando llegó bukele al poder
en 2019 la tasa era de 38 homicidios por
cada cien mil habitantes esta medida se
ha posicionado como la más popular y es
a juicio del analista Mauricio maravilla
el pilar del actual popularidad del
mandatario el presidente Sí en su
estrategia de seguridad sí creo que tocó
una fibra sensible tiene costos por
supuesto en materia de Derechos Humanos
tiene costos altísimos pero la gente en
su mayoría eso no le preocupa porque
viene de un discurso de los gobiernos
anteriores que decía no la separación de
poderes etcétera Pero ahí estaban los
homicidios estaba la pobreza estaba la
desigualdad Entonces ahora el presidente
por lo menos le dice a la gente yo le
estoy resolviendo un problema básico
después de miles de capturas el gobierno
asegura que aún el trabajo continúa y
que renovará el régimen de excepción las
veces que sea necesario hasta capturar
al último pandillero Mientras tanto la
ong Cristofer lleva registradas de 4.000
denuncias de violaciones de Derechos
Humanos principalmente por detenciones
arbitrarias Además del registro por la
muerte dentro de las cárceles de más de
150 personas capturadas durante el
régimen muchos de ellos con evidencias
de haber sufrido violencia o tortura
sistémica
el informe de la oficina de alto
comisionado de Naciones Unidas para los
Derechos Humanos pidió recientemente al
gobierno de bukele que investigue esas
muertes y que ponga fin al Estado de
excepción De igual forma se refirió a
los riesgos que corren trabajadores de
medios de comunicación en un entorno de
ataques y desacreditación recurrente
según la asociación de periodistas de El
Salvador durante el 2022 hubo 136 casos
de agresiones a periodistas
ha habido un aumento de censura de
periodistas y de movilizaciones internas
de colegas que están sufriendo acosos
por parte de autoridades de la Policía
Nacional civil y la Fuerza Armada hemos
identificado que hay periodistas que han
hecho coberturas del tema del régimen
que se han visto obligados a salir de
sus casas de habitación porque la
policía los anda buscando bajo supuestos
accidentes que han cometido en el
discurso por su cuarto año de gobierno
nayib bukele abrió otro frente de guerra
esta vez contra la corrupción y aseveró
que será tan agresivo como el que existe
contra las pandillas se refirió
básicamente a la corrupción del pasado y
no a los señalamientos que existen sobre
algunos de sus funcionarios decir el
presidente no puede presumir de una
estrategia de combate a la corrupción si
lo hace de manera selectiva si ordena al
fiscal general de la república que no es
para nadie independiente perseguir a
unos corruptos del pasado
y hacerse de la vista gorda con las
acusaciones de corrupción en la
actualidad entonces hay varios elementos
que nos indican que este control sobre
la institucionalidad nos va a llevar a
mayores abusos de poder la arremetida
contra las pandillas y la corrupción
podrían darle a bukele el boleto hacia
la reelección en los comicios del 2024
pese a los señalamientos de ser
inconstitucional el actual mandatario
tiene el camino allanado cuenta con una
alta popularidad entre el 80 y 90 por
ciento según recientes estudios una
oposición política diezmada y el control
de la institucionalidad de los tres
poderes del Estado llegamos así al final
del enlace Centroamérica desde el
Salvador continúe con nosotros en plans
24 y planes 24.com
[Música]